buongiorno dove esternando dove vai
ovvie mamma e gianmarco spero che non
sia vestito da di pietro però ce lo
siamo arrivati qui siamo messi male
commissione 15 a passeggio riti per
ragazzi ma sta più dentro al sole si
pestino le streghe dici allora qua fa
freddo sono a mezze maniche vi giuro che
non è per farvi vedere la maglietta non
solo resta una fede il patto non si va
più tanto per prevedere questa roba qui
guarda che bello io in questa zona della
casa stupenda di questi riflessi oddio
freddo che a mangiarmi che stiamo
facendo ci siamo ubriacando stiamo
aspettando parenti da catania vivi nel
frattempo viviamo
ci sarà lui a cannes dove dall'olio di
danze mamma mia
nel giro di pochi minuti potrebbe
cambiare
poi riguardo si è lavato finalmente ce
n'è fatta mi sono picchi in anteprima
poi gliela facciamo la piastra cose
roberts anzi no le donne
copyright enrico dammi un biscotto ci
parlo sopra si vanno a sommare e
gabriele finora poco mi spoglio cosa
come detto metti mangia niente
[Musica]
il progetto
la sobrietà del 20 la caponata
chi è non ne faccio parlare
andiamo stiamo andando a fare una cosa
molto carina come stare a casa edizioni
stiamo per regalare un gioco da tavola
che ha ideato il mio nonno era molto
legato il mio nonno nel passato con tre
giochi da tavolo per regalare uno di
quelli che è uno dei più famosi ma
perché il clima sporche male per grillo
possiamo far vedere un attimo i calzini
gabriele scorpion e sub di uno
spettacolare portano proprio nel sacco
nero che non si capisce questo cosa sia
lì davanti a se sì perché questa fissa
che devono essere resistenti le cose 15
a scatole il ferro battuto si aspetta
bello senza mancar in manutenzione ma
non ti sente all'apparecchio rustico
pure lui
[Applauso]
reparti totale al narcotrafficante mondo
pronto allora addio questo 12 tonnellate
è un altissimo diciamo del nostro regalo
di noi
i voti a tutti questa è l'originalità
monografico che passasse anche questo e
agris ico primordiale e poi modelli e
siete delle bestie che la scienza e
intelligenza e la sublimità del cervello
di mio zio e bravi tutti enrico a
giocare ora stanzino
[Musica]
tutti sbagliati e asciugati svelate
usando del nostro nonno ha costruito
guerre base ovvero altra strategia 40
anni prima i russi serissima sta
mangiando arance non siamo sbucciando
come adesso una sono chiare lista era lì
dalla nostra terra queste le puoi tirare
senza inquinare che poi tirano già
chiude la falla è capito adesso mio zio
vuole regalare una macchina a mia zia
parliamo però spingere gli sta regalando
un'altra gara nonché perché dobbiamo
fingere che indicano uno strano mangiare
questo blog è un po rallentato perché
abbiamo bevuto un pochino ragazzi
guardate che c'è è uscito uno spicchio
per la parola possa avere una specie di
valerio panino
allora adesso dobbiamo prendere quella
macchina e far finta che sia il regalo
per zia ma in realtà non è quella con
quella grigia ma in fondo
voglio dire che abbiamo fatto un fiocco
sul cofano molto bello che era attaccate
via civitali siccome vi aveva per
spostarla a nasconderla saverio attivati
da civiltà contro il mondo quel fiocco
una mettete mai facciamolo
chi dalla macchina qui a un bidone ma io
lo metterà questo fiocco no andiamo come
se avessimo preso un polipo il tiranno
la nostra famiglia noi regaliamo
soltanto macbook pro è bello far parte
di questa famiglia come si fa
non siamo pronti come no che sembrava
che stessimo proprio per partire la come
va beh allora avete i dieci ragazzi
abbiamo poco tempo ma le chiavi della
macchina che con tale galileo fresca
secondo te può uscire un nodo pomposo no
troppo bagnato nascondiamo 5 rega
entrato in macchina che loro sono gialla
ok situazioni attuali loro sono milano
le maniche ok non più le mani che la
faccia se buio allora loro sono di
lavoro i fichi e noi siamo qui con il
real beef con il nodo di merda
quello che sono riusciti a creare ma non
riusciamo a passare grazie tesoro
l'attrezzata ma quant'è bello quel
bianco zia
grande raval del grande eduardo chico
mestiere faccia presto ad accenderli
cammino non c'è chi ti fa da sfondo con
la quale l'altro fratello migliora
insegna proprio come che cosa c'è cosa
c'è i miei cugini sono i più grandi
cacasotto a partire da guglielmo un
gioco ci ho dormito e lo ha ospitato in
casa mia tranquillamente quindi
cacasotto
rar e improvvisamente è diventato un
certo comunque secondo me ragazzi
gabriele valeva di buttarsi in piscina
non ci credo ma mai detto mamma ma come
pensate di casa potrebbe darle se volete
che io mi butto in piscina lappatura
patto ragazzo peruviano vigilia natale
un pensiero ce lo faccio vada anche tu
chi vuoi che vada a farsi il bagno 26 st
cruz è bello zampatti rampazzo immensi
si possono dire di buttare il mio amico
gabriele non si inquadra favore io ho
paura di che cosa è una vita il freddo e
il traffico signori siamo arrivati alla
fine di questo video sono andato in
aeroporto a prendere questa ragazza qui
seguita abbiamo fatto un avventura con
il ritorno che è stata un pochino
difficile perché ho sbagliato strada e
quindi abbiamo girato per 50 minuti
attorno a questo posto senza riuscire a
trovare la strada è ma nella per te il
penultimo episodio dove nell'ultimo non
si può chiudere così ciao ragazzi